we have covered two types of
multiplication problem so far first
problems like 98 times 97 when both
numbers were below the base and second
problems like 102 times 103 when both
numbers were above the base in both
cases the product of the deviations was
positive and we could write it on the
right but what if we have an example
like 13 times 8 here the base is 10 as
both the numbers are close to 10 13 as
we can see is above the base and 8 is
below the base let's see if the steps we
used earlier work for such problems as
well base deviations sum and product the
deviation of 13 from 10 will be 13 minus
10 3 and the deviation of 8 from 10 will
be 8 minus 10 and that is minus 2 sum on
the left and the product on the right
the sum can be 13 plus minus 2 which is
13 minus 2 or it can be 8 plus 3 both
give us 11 what about the product of the
deviations it will equal 3 times minus 2
and that is minus 6 now it gets tricky
we have a minus sign here so let's write
a minus 6 here can this be the answer
the number doesn't even make sense
11 and -6 the solution is very simple
actually we subtract a 1 from the left
hand figure and add the base to the
right hand figure adding the base will
give us 10 plus minus 6 which equals 10
minus 6 11 minus 1 is 10 and 10 minus 6
is 4 but wait before writing for we
should check the number of digits that
are allowed on the right as the number
of zeros in the base is 1 the number of
digits on the right will also be 1 so we
write a 4 here that's our answer
104 so what we did was very simple
whenever we have a negative number on
the right we subtract one from the left
hand figure and add the base to the
right hand figure why do we do this the
logic is simple this is the hundreds
place this is the tens place and this is
the unit's place so in place value terms
this can be written as one multiplied by
100 plus 1 multiplied by 10 plus minus
six x one we just multiplied each digit
with its place value 100 plus 10 is 110
and -6 times 1 is -6 110 minus 6 will
equal 104 so if you get confused trying
to remember this you should use place
value logic to arrive at the answer I
know all this was too painful for
finding the solution of 13 times 8 we
will look at some tougher examples with
bigger numbers like 105 times 97 or one
thousand seven times 998 in the next
part of this session